what's it like to come to the Grammys
get nominated as a Best New Artist what
is that like oh my gosh well I have to
say that I've been watching
like oh my God I can't believe you're
actually real but it's got him come on
how was this moment because this is your
moment I'm here I'm here I'm just a dude
but what is this like to have your
moment
this means everything you know I I
started seeing Jazz about six to seven
years ago and you know from The Help
from the help of my college from the
help of my parents who are also here
um and from the help of my friends my
team I just I can't I couldn't have
imagined being I'm born and raised in
the Bronx New York and I grew up with
music all my life but I just never
imagined getting to this point I are
your parents here are they here oh
they're going to see them at the
ceremony we'll see him at the ceremony
what does that mean what are you looking
forward to tonight in this show
well I'm thankfully I'm not performing
tonight there's so many great artists
I'm like I'm gonna have a seat and watch
and learn you know but I'm excited to
see everybody's I heard Jay-Z's
performing yes he is I hope that means
Beyonce is too
um
Maybe not maybe maybe we'll see but I'm
just looking forward to everything about
it my little brother is my date so I'm
gonna walk the red carpet with him
you're coming he's coming so your
brother's out there somewhere he's your
big brother he's six uh six five and
twenty years old
congratulations this is a it's a moment
right and do you feel it I feel
I feel